hello I'm Alan McLeod and today we're
going to tell the story of the curse of
Giles Corey our story begins in Salem
Massachusetts the Puritans had just
settled the colony and they were very
much into biblical law so a bunch of
girls started acting erratically and a
doctor checked them out and he said
these girls are bewitched and thus began
a Salem witch trials
so these witch trials start and Martha
and Giles Corey are just like eating
popcorn and enjoying themselves and
they're going in there and they're
excited about it and they're like oh I
love you honey and we're at the west
trials and isn't it fun that there might
be witches among us so the Puritans were
not very scientific you wouldn't have to
like pee into a cup and then they would
like pour the pee into like a cake and
then a dog would have to eat the cake
and then if and the person who peed into
the cake felt pain when the dog ate the
cake then that person was a witch and
Martha's like that doesn't make any
sense as far as like judging whether
you're a witch or not so and Putnam was
like you're a witch because you're
criticizing us and so sheriff George
Corwin came in and was like you're
accused of being witch he's gonna get
hung and that's it the trial is is
arbitrary it's not really oh shoot Zak
was that first a little something coming
up dog okay good boy the quarry goes to
trial and Giles Corey was just swept up
in the hysteria of the whole
he's like well our cat died and that
could be a sign of wish and also my ox
has been having some issues so she could
be a witch I mean I don't know but she
could be a witch
well then Martha goes to jail and Giles
is like I've been caught up in the whole
mania of the Salem witch trials and I
need to relax and come to my senses and
now that I've come to my senses I
realized my wife is not a wish and I I
was telling tales out of school and
everybody's like so wait a second you're
doubting us so you're questioning us
like that means you're a witch and the
jobs they snuck up to dude don't worry
about all right okay and so I'm sure if
corn comes in he says all right well
it's time for me to touch you baby
and my choice of torture is pnd for Tate
PN Will Forte god damn it
Pierre de totora so Giles Corey was
given the sentence of P na Forte at door
and that basically meant we're gonna put
this board on you and then we're gonna
put a bunch of rocks on top of you and
crush you until you plead guilty or not
guilty so they start putting rocks on
him and start pressing on him wait well
crush you the right way Oh your body on
top of a body okay anyway
like oppressing you your when she I'm
not which are you kissing Oh anyway all
that Joe says to them more wait I could
take it more way oh is that the biggest
heaviest rock you got more weight Oh
so for two days Giles Corey is being
crushed there and it got so bad that
Giles Corey's eyes were bulging out of
his head and his tongue was just outside
of his mouth
sheriff Corwin has come over there and
put them back in at the tip of his cane
he's like hey why don't you confess to
being which jaws was like you can kill
me now but I promise I curse you like I
curse you Sharon curve who I curse you
sheriff currant bush you sale them
neither their cups but I curse you cuz I
mean crush you all understand this later
sorry by Giles Corey's death was so
gruesome that it led to the end of the
Salem witch trials and then four years
later sheriff Corwin died of a heart
attack obviously they can't trace it
back to ya the curse but they all know
is the curse so in 1978 sheriff Robert
Cahill
had a heart attack it was like I should
just research on this curse that was put
on us by Giles and he found that every
sheriff in Salem had her type or stroke
he's like oh that curse was real
that was like there's a rule or ass
curse so they moved the Sheriff's
Department of second this is why lon
told stories of the you know Salem witch
trials can i press you real quick I
could die
[Music]